[Music]
welcome to the advanced networking demo
series my name is Susan Wu I'm in
outbound product management we're
talking about the network function
Optimizer with me I have my colleague
deac Michael he's a network specialist
and customer engineer in Cloud
networking so what is the network
function Optimizer it's actually a
product Suite with Advanced container
networking features for the deployment
and acceleration of network intensive
workloads Network intensive workloads
could include AIML workloads that
require high bandwidth and low latency
running on gpus they could be
containerized Network
functions containerized firewalls V
routers VPN proxies they could be user
plane functions in Telco
networks so containers need additional
capabilities to handle the network
intensive
workloads they require multiple
interface VMS can have up to eight
interfaces pods only have
one they require Advanced IP management
VMS can be assigned public and private
IPS with
persistence pods have ephemeral
IPS they require high performance
features like
dbtk default uh
mtus support VMS similar support would
be needed for
containers a service steering so service
steering mechanisms and API definition
would be needed for the
pods so the netor function Optimizer can
bridge this Gap in four
ways firstly we provide multi Network
pods which enable multiple interfaces
for pods and nodes in the gka
cluster we provide a high performance
data plane so we deliver a
software-based high performance data
plane which removes the underlying
hardware and Nick
dependency thirdly we provide the fast
failover with persistent IPS so we can
map the application traffic to the
public IP and use the same IP to
initiate and receive
traffic lastly we provide kubernetes
based policy based traffic steering so
you can steer the traffic to The
Container Network functions using
kubernetes network
policy the benefits of using network
function Optimizer are threefold you get
the multi networking getting the
consistent interfaces for the Network
Services secondly you get the
acceleration so you can unlock the
workflow portability allowing workloads
to be scheduled to any pods without any
dependency thirdly you get anile network
infrastructure so you can achieve fast
failover with the native Integrations
with public IP bring your own IP and
network low
balancers we intend to Upstream this
work into the community and we've been
actively contributing to the Sig Network
this actually Le leverages the native
Linux acceleration to achieve the
comparable performance also we're
leveraging the native Google Cloud to
provide a cloud native approach to
networking now let me pass you to deepo
to see a walk through thanks Susan let's
jump into nfo requirements the first
step in creating a multi Nick pod is to
create a GK cluster and default no pool
with a regular and secondary Subnet in
addition you would need to enable the
flags enable data plane V2 and enable
multi
Network once deployed create or use
existing vpcs for subnet and IP address
allocation for multi- Nick pods and data
communication to VPC workloads identify
your multi- Nick requirements do you
need a net device or L3 device type net
device is used to communicate to GC
instances in a VPC using a regular
subnet range while L3 device type
utilizes the VPC secondary subnet range
to commun Comm unicate to GK services or
Docker containers running on
GCE when creating a multi build pool you
are required to deploy a machine type
vcpu equal or greater than the number of
vpcs in your deployment as an example in
our deployment there are three vpcs
hence we will configure a machine type
with four
DCP since the not prerequisites are
satisfied you can create an L3 and net
device pod Network lastly deploy multi-
pods or deployments by leveraging the
interface name annotation compris of the
ethernet interface and network let's go
over the dental architecture and
validation use case we have a Google
Cloud project that contains a global VPC
named primary VPC with a GK cluster
deployed in US Central One the GK
cluster consists of a default node pool
and network deployed with the flag
enabled data plane V2 and enable multi
networking within the project we also
have our net device and L3
vpcs the multin no tool is created by
specifying the cluster the net device
VPC L3 VPC pod Network and machine type
in our first use case we will perform a
SSH into a net devis pod and validate
connectivity to the net device theat
incense and the net device CPC via E2
are perform a w get against the Apache
server IP address we will also perform a
similar test this time accepting the L3
Apache server in the L3 VPC via E1
validated by a
WG let's take a look at our Second Use
case we will perform an SSH into the L3
Network pod and validate connectivity to
the L3 Apache incense in the L3 VPC via
E1 by per forming a WG against the L3
aach that concludes the demo
architecture time to jump in to the
deployment okay let's jump into the demo
deployment first off let's look at the
VPC networks the L3
DPC we're going to look at the secondary
subnet this is the IP subnet range that
the multi nickp would take when
deploying at L3 type
interface now now let's look at the net
device
VPC and as a name suggests this is the
subnet that's going to be used when and
net device uh interfaces being utilized
which is also called a regular sub
range lastly let's look at the primary
VPC this is where the default node pool
will be deployed and also your ethernet
zero will pick up an IP address from the
secondary range primary bpc subnet
that's
defined awesome now looking at the
firewall rules we don't have any uh
we'll come back and we'll update the
firewall rules later in the
deployment okay looking at cloudnet we
have cloudnet tooy in each one of the
dpcs in US Central One utilized for
internet
erass and taking a look at the compute
engine these are the GC instances
running Apache server L3 Apache andet
device Apache they'll be used for
validation later in the
deployment we don't have any clusters
deployed um as a prre it we will need to
deploy a new cluster for multin neck
node pools which we're going to go ahead
and do right now so opening up a cloud
shell and let's look at the the flags
enable multi
networking and the enable data plane V2
these are the two required Flags when
creating a cluster
all
right refresh okay great the cluster is
up
now let's take a look at the IP
addresses used in the VPC great it's the
primary
VPC and it has the right IPS that are
that we called out
earlier we can look at this um from the
nodes perspective as well we got the
default
pool
great and just another breakdown of how
this all works together you can see the
primary
VPC is used for the network and the
subnet the primary node subnet and then
the Pod IP address rings and that IP
address will be used for ethernet zero
when dep
positive okay let's go ahead and create
our multi Nick node
pool change the name to m Nick node
pool everything else is fine here terms
of defaults however in the node section
we do need to change the machine type
since we have three vpcs we would need
at least three
vcpus therefore we're going to make a
change to the n vcpus in this machine to
four yeah
awesome now under networking this first
section this is for the default node
pool
and yeah the secondary range is in play
and you can see that because we specify
the primary VPC now the second section
yeah this is for the L3 type device and
the L3 VPC we have a regular subnet then
we also need to Define the secondary
subnet right so this is the subnet where
the mic pod is going to pull an IP
address lastly we have the net device
VPC and it's going to use a regular
subnet called net device subnet
okay we're good to go here security
metadata everything is default and let's
go ahead and create the multi code
pool awesome so the multi Nick node pool
is now
instantiated jump into it and you could
see the networking components we have
the primary
VPC the L3 VPC as well
awesome the secondary range is
specified and then we have the net
device
VPC he looking
good okay a network function Optimizer
we have the default Network which is
using their primary VPC that's the the
default node pool and it's also
associated with the multi Nick node pool
so keep that in
mind and we'll go ahead and jump into
this but I do want to look at the
command line here at cctl let's look at
the networks we only have one the defa
network in this section of the
deployment we're going to create the
multipod network we've met the pr Rex
we've defined vpcs and Associated
subnets for the L3 device type and the
net device so let's specify the cluster
in
use and the VPC that we're so we're
going to Target here is the L3
VPC and the network type there's options
L3 dpdk net device this is going to be
the L3 Network and remember for the L3
Network we need to find a secondary
range which we're doing here got it
awesome and we're going to Define routes
to the L3 Apache server 17 26
20.0 okay awesome so we see the network
now it's defined let's take a look here
yep it's um you can see here in command
line as
well now if we want to look into the
details a little bit further you can see
the network definition we had the routes
that we specified and then type as
L3 okay looking good let's look at the
gke pram set for the L3 Network here you
get a little bit more information as
well you can see the actual VPC in use
the L3 VPC and the
7et it's a lot of good information there
to look at and then again you can look
at that through the cloud console as
well now let's go and create the next
one specify the cluster in
use the VPC Network this is going to be
the net device if youc okay got it and
the Pod network type we're use net
device and let's give it the name net
device APC okay great secondary arrange
if we don't need one it's not not
required for net device remember so
that's only for the L3 type awesome
let's go and create our routes and this
route is going to be for the net device
Apache okay great we got our three
networks
now let's take a deeper look into the
configuration parameters
describe on the
network yeah looking at the network a
little bit deeper then we have the net
device Network we have the routes the
17216 10.0 that's to the net device
Apache
subnet and looking at the GTE pram sets
I like looking at this one there's more
information here which is useful so yeah
it defines the VPC and the subnet so
awesome so everything is mapped up
accordingly let's go ahead and move on
and create a pod we'll go ahead and VI
this pod net device L3 pod yaml Dro in
the yaml
configuration we have the default
interface which is going to be ethernet
zero that's going to be standard
ethernet zero is also your default
Network ethernet one L3 Network and
ethernet 2 the net device
Network all right so the pods up and
running taking a closer look at the yaml
we could obtain the IP addresses that
are associated with the different
networks again the ethernet zero is
default ethernet one is the L3 ethernet
2 is the net device but what I want to
do is cross reference the
vpcs and look at the IP address a little
bit deeper all right so L3 we got a
10834 that lines up to the secondary
ipv4 range
now let's take a look at the net
device that's using that regular subnet
so that's a
192168 10.24 and that lines up to 10.0
sl24
perfect ethernet Zer is going to pull an
IP address
1035 that's from the primary
VPC and that's the secondary
range from that yeah 10
01 okay
awesome now SSAT into the Pod and we'll
do an
iake validate it once more and
everything Ls
up at this point let's look at the route
table so IP route and we can see the
routes that are being utilized for both
ethernet 2 and ethernet
[Music]
one also so we picked up our NEX hops as
well so that looks correct we'll
validate that
later using a ping and a w get so now
we're going to create the L3 pod same
thing so the ethernet0 is going to be
the default interface ethernet zero is
also going to be defined by the network
default ethernet one with the network L3
Network same type of busy box pod so
this looks good let's go to and deploy
it go ahead and apply the
config
okay yeah the pods up and running look
at the yimo file see what type of ips we
picked
up yeah so everything looks good here
EET zero
default the ET one is going to be using
the L3 Network so that lines up and and
we picked up an IP address from the L3
Network as well the
1087 awesome uh I do like cross
referencing the
config now let's look at the L3 Network
yeah
10821 awesome and the ethernet zero
interface 1015 and that's from the
primary
VPC
okay so we only have two interfaces on
this pod ethernet zero and ethernet
one okay we'll SSH into the
Pod same everything lines up same config
that we saw in the running
config and take a look at the IP route
table and we have the EET
one okay looks like everything is in
order
here okay our pods are now validated
let's go ahead and test connectivity to
do so we need to create Ingress firewall
rules the first one allows the net
device subnet access to a net device of
Pat
server we will then create a PowerAll
rule to allow the SE range El 3 subnet
access to the L3 Apache
C remember both of these subnets
contain interfaces for the multin neck
pod okay so that's validated as well
let's go ahead and get the IP addresses
of the Apache server so we know what
interface to
reach we got the L3 Apache met device
Apache
okay great got the internal
IPS now let's go ahead and do some
validation with the Ping and the wget
the first one's from the net device L3
pod here we're going to go ahead and
Target the L3 Apache server which is
successful and then we're going to
Target the net device Apache server
which is successful as well
great let's go ahead and do a w get on
the same server so again to the L3
Apache that
works and let's go ahead and try this
with the net device Apache
server and that's successful too awesome
so both ethernet interface one and two
are in use all right let's move to the
L3
pod and from the L3 pod we're going to
go ahead and try
in the net device Apache server and that
won't work because we don't have an
Ethernet interface that is linked to
that Network so that
failed have our ping to the L3 Apache
server is
successful okay let's follow up with a W
get and this will work too because we
have a ethernet interface one which is
connected as a final validation step
let's leverage logging explor to view
logs of can when we enabled Ingress
farall rules log in the login capture
you can see two enties one per pod that
contains a rip set of metadata
consisting of Po IP address in this case
EET one destination node name Tool port
and protocall as a best practice it's
recommended to nameable firewall log for
troubleshooting and for
to learn more about Network function
Optimizer please check out the Cod laab
and documentation links in the
description thank you for
watching